quand il est un peu fâché ou qui essaye
de mordre
c'est des dents super fine en fait
en liberté on va pas trop le stresser
quand même
pour s'enfoncer encore plus loin dans la
jungle Sébastien doit changer de mode de
transport
donc le reste du trajet ça va être
principalement tyrolienne
on va économiser peut-être 4 heures de
marche en une demi-heure on se retrouve
au milieu de la forêt primaire
[Musique]
si l'accès est aussi difficile c'est que
l'enjeu est de taille
dans le parc de bokeo ce qui attire les
touristes du monde entier ce sont les
derniers Gibbons noirs du Laos des
singes très rares en voie de disparition
[Musique]
pour avoir une chance de les observer un
seul moyen
des maisons construites directement dans
les arbres à 40 mètres de hauteur
au-dessus de la canopée
[Musique]
voici le décor de la nouvelle vie de
Thomas ancienne informaticien en
Auvergne il a démissionné il y a 6 ans
pour vivre son rêve ce que j'ai dit à
mes collègues en partant c'est que
nos ancêtres sont descendus des arbres
pour éventuellement finir devant la
réalité virtuelle d'un écran et moi j'ai
décidé de
retourner dans l'arbre
de son côté Sébastien lui récupère va
voir si elle marche bien voilà
pour Thomas c'est l'heure de la douche
ah quel bonheur
la journée c'est un tranquillement le
matin suivant c'est le chant des gibbons
qui réveillera nos deux amis
avant de retourner aux sirènes
d'ambulance Sébastien lui profite de la
mélodie des gibbons
[Musique]
c'est un petit jeu
puis devant ses yeux un spectacle unique
et le petit qui est passé une famille de
Gibbon vient prendre son petit déjeuner
dans le même arbre qu'une famille
d'oiseaux
alors là on voit les oiseaux qui
défendent de nous
le gibbon s'approche d'une nuit donc ils
sont de plus en plus nerveux
et font des attaques
et c'est la première fois que je les
vois aussi près
ils sont ils sont à combien là ils sont
à 30 mètres
dans quelques heures Sébastien descendra
de son arbre pour rejoindre son équipe
de secours à Vienne
comme Laurence
ou Simon
il a choisi le Laos comme terre
d'accueil pour mener son combat
[Musique]